I think everyone knows about the beauty
of Joon sunscreen if you don't it is
super popular right now because it's so
light and comfortable while still being
protective and really budget friendly
but beauty of Joon has so many other
fantastic budget friendly skincare
products some of which are really
underrated I'm going to tell you about
some of the best ones today I'm Michelle
of lab muffin Beauty science chemistry
PhD cosmetic chemist and most
importantly skincare connoisseur let's
get into it this video is sponsored by
sty Korean who stocked K beauty products
from tons of different brands including
beauty of Choson I'm going to start with
possibly the second most hyped up beauty
of Choson product although I still think
it's less popular than it should be it
is the revive eye serum jinsang and
retinal this is an eye product but a lot
of people actually just use it all over
their face the main draw card here for
most people is the retinal which is
considered the strongest form of vitamin
A that you get in cosmetic skincare
products it's only one conversion away
from retinoic Acid so it's one step
closer than retinol Korean products tend
not to use a lot of vitamin A but it is
starting to increase I think this is
still the only Korean product I've seen
that has rean now it is one of the if
not the most budget friendly retinal
products available this has 0.02%
retinal encapsulated in liposomes which
makes it a really gentle product
basically the retinal is inside these
little packets and it gets released more
slowly onto skin the liposomes also help
keep it stable and there are also
soothing ingredients in this there's
nide ginang vitamin E and adenosine all
of these help reduce a bit of that
irritation and the gy sang is also meant
to have some anti- wrinkle benefits this
is one of the gentler retinal SL retinol
products I've tried but I do know that
some people have still got an irritation
from it so if you're new to these
stronger retinoids or if you know that
your skin finds retinoids a little bit
spicy I would recommend introducing this
really slowly I have a video on how to
start on retinoids that have a lot of
tips for how to slowly introduce your
skin to it but I have found that I can
use the serum every day if I'm just a
little bit careful with it and don't use
like way too much which is how you are
meant to use retinoid you only need
about a PE size amount for your whole
face this is fragrance-free I know a lot
of people whose skin can't handle
fragrance often have issues finding K
beauty products so if that is you boj
should be on your radar because most of
their products are fragrance-free and
this leads me on to the radiance
cleansing balm I am a huge fan of
cleansing balms I really enjoy them for
melting off makeup and sunscreen sort of
effortlessly before then using a regular
cleanser I just find it really relaxing
to like massage my face while I take my
makeup off at the end of the day it is
honestly my favorite step in my skincare
routine that I look forward to all day
it's kind of like the face or skincare
equivalent of kicking off your shoes a
lot of people have asked me about
fragrance-free cleansing balms that have
smooth textures that still rinse off
nicely and this is one of the very few
out there and unlike a lot of other
fragrance-free cleansing products this
actually barely smells like anything
anything it still has that really
lightweight kind of melty texture that a
lot of other Korean cleansing balms have
minus the fragrance so if your skin is
sensitive to fragrance then this is a
really good option that doesn't really
compromise on much the tub also has this
really handy flip top lid which is much
nicer than a screw top when your hands
are like oily and slippery it has a
spatula if you are into spatulas I'm not
really that into spatulas I find it
really satisfying to just like gouge my
finger into the hole of the cleansing
balm I do get a lot of products with
spatulas I've actually got them in this
giant collection right here I don't know
if anyone's noticed this anyway this is
a really nice product and I think it is
relatively unique now on the topic of
cleansing let's move on to the green
plum refreshing cleanser this is a
really lovely inoffensive cleanser and
inoffensive is really what you want from
a cleanser it should clean well without
messing up your skin so your skin is
nicely prepared for the rest of your
skincare routine it also Foams really
well but it doesn't dry out your skin I
would say that this is actually one of
the most hydrating cleansers I've used
there was Zero tightness on my skin
after using this there are a bunch of
antioxidants in it which can potentially
help reduce a bit of that cleansing
irritation and it is slightly acidic to
match your Skin's natural pH with a lot
of foaming Kine cleansers you tend to
get this really amazing fluffy dense
foam but then they have a really high ph
and that tends to help strip your skin
and irritate it if your skin is prone to
dehydration which my skin very much is
it does take a little bit more effort to
get like a fluffy leather with this
compared to those more drying cleanser
formulas but I think it is really worth
it I am a huge fan of hydrating
cleansers because it feels like you
don't need to use as many hydrating
products after cleansing you don't have
to load up your skin again with
hydrating toners and serums just to get
your skin back to Baseline before you go
and apply the rest of your skincare
again this is a fragrance free cleanser
so another really good option if your
skin doesn't like fragrance I feel like
I have already raved about the relief
sun rise and probiotics so many times
but I'm going to quickly run through it
in case for those of you who are new to
beauty of chosen this is possibly the
most raved about sunscreen online at the
moment and it is my favorite sunscreen
that I've tried so far it is a Korean
sunscreen that's not approved in other
countries as far as I know it is pretty
lightweight but on the more moisturizing
side which I have personally really
appreciate it my skin is sort of oily
combination but it has been drying out a
bit because I've been using a lot more
retinoids which a bit drying and I've
also had some hormonal changes thanks to
dealing with endometriosis the texture
is really beautifully smooth and buttery
it's made by one of korean's top
sunscreen manufacturers there is a tiny
bit of white cast when I first apply it
but it goes away once I leave it for
about 10 minutes on the topic of rubbing
and white cast you shouldn't be rubbing
your sunscreen in a whole bunch to try
to get rid of that white cust the more
you rub the more it drops the protection
of the sunscreen it can drop it by quite
a lot so just put it on and let it sit
the downside of the Sun sun screen is
that because it is so popular there's
been quite a few fakes floating around
like on Amazon so if you are planning to
buy this I highly recommend buying it
from an official retailer like sty
Korean my next pick is the apricot
Blossom peeling gel is it just me or is
everyone sleeping on peeling gels I feel
like I don't really see other skincare
creators talk about them but maybe I
just haven't seen them let me know in
the comments if you're a peeling gel fan
or if you know where all the peeling gel
fans are hiding I've been using a
peeling gel maybe 2 or three times wig
for more than the last 10 years maybe
the last 15 peeling gels are one of my
top underrated products that I really
feel need more love and this is a really
good one they are basically really
gentle physical exfoliants the reason
everyone hates on physical exfoliants is
just that a lot of people tend to
overuse them and that is pretty easy to
do if they've got really rough particles
things like apricot seed or ground pmus
or like salt particles a lot of people
start using scrubs when they start on
skincare they're looking for for
something to deal with acne and then
they just use those and use them way too
hard and that just irritates the crap
out of their skin that also happen with
overusing cleansing brushes which is
another form of physical exfoliation and
all of this has just given physical
exfoliant a really bad name but physical
exfoliation isn't all bad it's actually
really fantastic for immediately
smoothing the surface of your skin when
you use it in moderation that's the
important part moderation and if you
have a physical exfoliant that's really
gentle you can probably use it in
combination with chemical exfoliation
without overly stripping your skin and
of course that will depend on your skin
so that's why peing gels are great they
have the softest cellulose fibers as
they're scrubbing particles these are
the same sorts of fibers that you see in
wet tissues when they're sort of like
falling apart and so these are super
soft fibers that aren't going to scratch
your face no matter how hard you press
when you put one of these on your skin
the oil from your skin starts making the
fibers Bunch up and turns them into
larger soft scrubbing strings there are
some products that say it is dead skin
but it is not if it was dead skin it
would not be a gentle product and even
though those fibers are really soft I
find that they're really thorough
peeling gels are just really good at
getting dead skin off my skin compared
to something that feels a lot harsher
like a scrub a standard scrub that has
hard particles and that's especially in
the parts around my nose where it kind
of feels like it's hard to get to with a
physical exfoliant this just works
really well now if you press too hard
you can still end up irritating your
skin because you just have way too much
friction but you have to try a lot
harder to overuse a peeling gel and they
have made such a difference to my skin
one little use case that I love is when
I have dry flakes around my nose like
when I'm blowing my nose a lot I've had
a cold or I've had allergies and then I
put on foundation and the foundation
gets caught in the flakes and it makes
them look really obvious if I have a
peeling gel and I use it really gently
just buffing it in little circles and
rinsing it off before putting on makeup
that stops this from happening and it
kind of breaks off the flakes really
close to the skin and yeah exfoliating
irritator skin is not really best
practice but it is a lot better than the
alternative which is me trying to pluck
off like Foundation colored Flakes with
a pair of tweezers afterwards which ends
up ripping off skin that is still
attached and leaving raw Exposed Skin
it's really gross and if you are someone
who also does this please do yourself a
favor and use a peeling gel instead this
is one of my favorite peeling gels I've
tried my big test of whether a peeling
gel is good is whether or not it bunches
up and gives enough scrubbing fibers
when I use it in the shower when there's
lots of extra water around this one
works really really well but a lot of
them don't and they turn kind of sad and
watery some of them actually go kind of
sticky and stick to all your like little
hairs and maybe that's why people don't
love peeling gels they've been using the
wrong ones but yeah this one passes with
flying colors and again it is
fragrance-free and it has minimal smell
for a fragrance-free product which again
is rare for a pealing gel now what is
actually best practice for irritated
flaking skin is segue a hydrating
product this is the jinang essence water
it's a hydrating toner this sort of
product is really popular in Asian
skincare for just adding a layer of
lightweight hydration to your skin
without adding stuff that sits
noticeably on the surface this doesn't
leave any residue on your face so
there's just a lot less chance of this
making another product boil up on your
skin so this is perfect for under
sunscreen or under makeup it's also
really good as one of the earlier steps
in an evening routine I would apply this
right after cleansing before any other
actives or serums this sort of product
is also really handy when your skin is
super dehydrated and your regular
moisturizer isn't quite doing enough so
instead of trying to find a whole new
moisturizer you can just add another
hydrating product underneath and
together they can hydrate enough I found
this super useful for applying to my
skin right after cleansing it stops my
skin from drying out if I wait a bit too
long before my other steps this is super
hydrating it's got a lot of Glycerin
it's also got hyaluronic acid and it
leaves a kind of plump hydrated feeling
on my skin that is just shy of being
tacky and that is such a hard balance to
get in a product like that maximum
plumpness but just not sticky although I
can't guarantee that it will hit that
spot for everyone else it depends on how
humid your environment is it depends on
your skin but it does hit that spot for
me so there is a chance there's no extra
oil in this either so again just less
stuff on your face there are a lot of
types of gensen extract in this which
have lots of antioxidants as well as
nomid so this is a really good way of
adding nide and antioxidants and ginsing
to your routine without adding much
weight or stickiness the lack of oil is
also awesome for when you need something
in summer to just hydrate and soothe
your skin but you can't handle any extra
oil on your face I use this as my hot
weather moisturizing product at night a
lot and just skip moisturizer again it
is fragrance-free and to me it smells
like nothing beauty of joson have a
bunch of serums and out of them my
favorite one that I've tried so far is
the glow serum which has propolis and NY
cinnamide it took me a really long time
to get into propolis because I always
just assumed it was like the same as be
Venom it just sounded like a really
irritating ingredient that was meant to
be good for acne and nothing else and I
felt like I already fell into that trap
with all those teenage acne products
that just burn so I avoided it for a
really long time but it turns out that
propess is like the opposite of that it
is really non-irritating after I saw
Kelly Driscoll Rave about propess a
whole bunch of times I finally decided
to look more into it and try it out and
it turns out that my skin really loves
it and this is actually one of Kelly's
top Ser which is why I tried it in the
first place Kelly is really good for K
Beauty reviews I end up loving a lot of
the products she recommends propess is
really nice and soothing it's great for
breakouts and I think that's because it
is made from plant app the bees
basically eat it and turn it into
concentrated antioxidants it's also
really hydrating and humant it has a bit
of a sticky texture but in a lot of
products it is diluted enough so it's
not really offensively sticky this isn't
sticky but it does have that tacky
hydrating texture there's also 2% nomid
and 5% salicylic acid both of these are
great at evening out skin tone which is
one of those components of glow someday
I might do a proper video breaking down
exactly what glowing skin actually is
but basically this serum ticks off a
whole bunch of the boxes for it even
skin tone smoother skin and hydration
this is just a really lovely product
that I use on my face when I want my
skin to look smooth and even the next
day without having to risk any
irritation and it is one of the few
products that I can use for that when my
skin is irritated without having to
worry about making it worse I hope you
enjoyed this video if you did hit the
like let me know if you tried any of
these products before and what you
thought if you want more product reviews
you can check out this playlist where
I've ranked Reddit top Asian skincare
products thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time